and we had the highest ratings because
of Brooks these women should be happy
they're back because of Brooks they
should be kissing the ground he walked
on there's a lot of Tears this year on
me I was really sad that I felt up
against an army that we're not willing
to move past his relationship with
Brooks that they won't let go why why
wouldn't they let it go were they in
love with him like why won't you let it
go what was yes he was my guy
the night she moved out I literally laid
in the street crying begging him not to
cut was there one thing that made you
want to come back I have a
responsibility to the viewers to you
know give them my truth and to be Who I
am and I I didn't want them to ever
believe that I was lying I just loved
hard I'm guilty of that I think my
breakup with Brooks was much harder than
both my marriages and that crazy Wow
that's married 30 years and I never
cried it never was heard as much as I
was with Brooks you know a year later do
I think about him now maybe once every
other month you know I usually talk to
him I feel like really good for him but
maybe he wasn't he wasn't right for me I
know I don't know why everything was so
picky it wasn't meant to be I guess I
have no bad feelings about him I mean
other than the fact what he did me at
the end I just had a great great ride
with him a lot of fun you never want to
see him speak of his name again I want
him out of my life I'm not part of some
scam and I think that he came up with
this plot or this this cancer thing so
people would be nice to him how can you
be mean to a man that has cancer was he
the love of your life or a love he was
he was the love of my life for five
years is that chapter closed for you now
well it'll never be closed for me
because anybody that I've been with I
will always love I know I didn't lie for
him and I know there's a lot of
questions that I'll never good answered
but I love them